last year I did a video on cyber
security Trends and in that I talked
about artificial intelligence and I
thought that was going to be important
it's turned out to be very important and
it's going to be even more important as
we go forward by the way is my hair
really that gray in the next deep fake
we're going to fix that okay let's take
a look at the future what I'm sure of is
that the future will look something like
the past and in fact one of the things
we'll see in the future are more AI
based threats but more on that in a few
minutes what we're going to see though
also is that change is the only constant
so that means things will be similar to
the past but there will also be new
things that we're going to take a look
at one of the new things that I think is
on the positive side is that we're going
to see a move away from passwords toward
pass Keys there's a new standard called
Pho that allows you to not have to send
a password but in fact do something that
is simpler easier to use and more secure
we don't normally get to do both of
those at the same time and we're going
to need it and what's the reason for
that well because AI as I mentioned is
going to be an increasing Threat Vector
for us AI based fishing emails are going
to become more and more common I expect
because they can generate what is very
convincing emails to get people to try
to log in or share their credentials in
ways that they shouldn't and this is a
very efficient way of doing it however
if you don't have a password in the
first place to send if you only have
something that is a secret that stays on
your system then there's no way for
someone to fish that out of you so that
this is going to be a good thing to try
to help against that now there are other
things that we can take a look at that
also in the AI space generative AI I
think we're going to see an increased
use of deep fakes these are things where
we simulate The Voice the image the like
Ness of an individual and in fact deep
fake technology has become so good and
it is so prevalent in fact if you have a
mobile phone it's probably already built
into your operating system in most cases
you may not know about it but it's there
so you could use this kind of technology
to fake someone out have them believe
something that's not true for instance
have uh someone call a relative and say
I need money it sounds like it's your
voice so they send the money so we're
going to need to do more in terms of
educating people about deep fakes and
the threat in that space because I think
we're going to see more of it and by the
way if you think deep fake detection is
going to be a good way to go I'm going
to ask you to think again about that
deep fake technology will always keep
getting better and it will eventually be
to the point where I don't think
detection is going to work uh in many
cases we've already seen this happen so
the focus needs to be not on detecting
the Deep fake with some sort of
Technology but building security
mechanisms around it so that we're not
reliant on the information that's in the
Deep fake itself other things that we're
going to take a look at would be a a
threat that comes to us from generative
Ai and that's hallucinations and by the
way you didn't think I was going to
actually write that word out when I have
a magic board that can autocomplete
that's what generative AI does right so
I'm leveraging that hallucinations we're
going to be more and more dependent upon
generative AI large language models and
chatbots to give us information the
problem is some of the information they
give us isn't always right and we call
those hallucinations and we're going to
make decisions based upon that that
could cause security threats to us so my
hope is that there will be other
Technologies things like uh retrieval
augmented generation or what we call rag
technology that will help reinforce and
make this system better and more
accurate other things that we can do to
tune the models and train them better so
that they don't hallucinate inate nearly
as much going forward and then finally
I'm going to say something I want to
leave you with a positive in terms of a
look at the future and that is there's
this symbiotic relationship between Ai
and cyber security and that is we're
going to use AI to do better job of
cyber security in fact there's a lot of
things that we can do in this space to
leverage generative AI in order to
better uh think about the way someone
would attack us
also summarize cases and things of that
sort so I think we're going to be able
to do a better job with cyber security
by leveraging AI by the same token we're
going to need to use our cyber security
skills in order to secure this AI so
that it can be trustworthy so that we
can in fact believe that the information
it gives us is true okay that's the
future and it's not a big surprise that
the future is very AI heavy however
there's a lot of existing threats that
have continued to persist and will
continue to persist as we move into the
future let's take a quick look at the
scorecard from last year's predictions
and see which ones of those actually
came true and which ones carry forward I
mentioned data breach last year when I
did the video and in fact it turns out
that the cost of a data breach has
continued to increase in fact now we're
on the order of $4.5 million on average
worldwide and in the US that number is
almost twice as high so that one uh I'm
going to say yeah came true ransomware
in fact we've continued to see
ransomware persist uh the the overall
numbers are a little bit down but the
amount of time it takes to run one of
these attacks has changed dramatically
this according to the xforce threat
intelligence index which says that back
in 2019 we were looking at 60 days on
average to deploy one of these now we're
down to about 4 days so this is kind of
a a a mixed bag you know this is uh it's
sort of true sort of not true but
ransomware is going to continue to be a
threat and it's a faster threat than it
used to be multiactor authentication I
don't know about you but I'm definitely
seeing more websites that are offering
this as an alternative and I'm taking
advantage and you should as well I think
we'll continue to see a lot more of that
as we go forward iot Internet of Things
threats yes in fact we've seen there was
one study that came out that said there
was in
a
400% increase in iot attacks in this
year uh 2023 so that one has definitely
continued we don't see that one changing
I already talked about AI that one's
only going to get bigger as we would
guess and then Quantum Computing I
talked about that one last year and in
particular that Quantum systems are
going to one day be able to crack our
cryptography they haven't effectively
done that yet but we're one year closer
to it so this is one of those you can
say well it's it's sort of true we're
definitely closer to the point when
that's going to become a real threat to
us uh not here exactly yet one bit of
good news I can report though that I was
partly right and partly wrong on and
that is this skills Gap so the skills
Gap actually moved from what was 770,000
open positions in the cyber security
space to now according to cyber.org we
are down to about 57 ,000 so that's an
improvement I predicted that we would
still have a skills Gap and we do but it
actually has has gone down a little bit
and I hope that continues to be the case
because we need a lot of good guys in
here who are going to be able to fight
the good
fight thanks for watching if you found
this video interesting and would like to
learn more about cyber security please
remember to hit like And subscribe to
this
channel